[Musique]
à
oui
ça lui est
salutaire
bienvenus du samedi soir bonsoir
elles ont très heureux de me retrouver
ceux ci désormais aux ravissantes ap
première carriole invité ce soir la plus
belle brésilienne de paris son testicule
et syna cordula
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez marc trévidic les meilleurs
juges antiterroristes français
jusqu'à ce que la règle des dix ans vous
envoie au tribunal de grande instance de
lille pour vous occuper des divorces
aujourd'hui votre combat
c'est contre la déprime
galud de mars et grégoire ludique du
palmashow
[Applaudissements]
la ville et grégoire le duo comique le
plus drôle de france et vous le prouver
une nouvelle fois avec votre long
métrage il ya qu un truc que je
comprends pas c'est pourquoi avoir
choisi un nom de boîte de strip-tease
aux baléares pas le macho pourquoi pas
ibiza knight et pourquoi pas mais
c'était bien pas le match au bon
souvenir des bizarres en piste trois
macarons notre terriens du samedi soir
ce soir la star du x manuel ferrara
des hlm de la banlieue parisienne aux
vinalies indienne un destin en or en p4
guillon 2017 et notre bataille des idées
consacré à la télévision avec gérard
yvan
patino voilà l'émission s'appelle salue
les canards le groupe le gréement de
fortune et le hashtag ces saletés
[Musique]
et maintenant voici mon cdd tom villa
j'adore
j'adore d'amusant prince est détruit
c'est plutôt 4 7 mois ça va tirer tout
va bien tout va bien on a un super
plateau bah oui très très beau plateau
le premier invité on la connaît depuis
des années ouais elle a toujours la même
coupe de cheveux elle a un fort accent
étranger non ce n'est pas dave mais
cristina cordula
[Applaudissements]
alors piscine à vous êtes vous êtes
brésilienne et vous êtes la spécialiste
de la mode alors c'est vrai que quand on
voir au jour de foot neymar david luiz
ronaldo ronaldinho on se dit qu'au
brésil le problème c'est pas les
fringues ainsi les coupes de cheveux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christina vous venez de sortir un livre
où vous revisitez les 30 basique du
dressing féminin
alors moi j'ai la suite à vous proposer
tenez ça c'est la garde-robe de thierry
ardisson suis pas sûr qu'on puisse en
faire un bouquin on sait jamais
noir foncé noir
mairie
voulait pas que je me change à chaque
fois je vous demande voulais pas non
mais pas du tout vous êtes très bien
noir toute façon on vous connaît un mois
depuis toujours ça fait bizarre si vous
changez d nous ça va pas le faire mais
c'est une star au portugal on dirait une
petite veut
[Rires]
haut de gamme cristina elle n'hésite pas
à donner son avis sur les personnalités
vous aviez dit françois hollande doit
arrêter de se teindre les cheveux en
noir les colorations avec une tête qui a
déjà vieilli ça ne va pas c'est pour ça
à brigitte bardot est là suivez votre
conseil s'est pas de couleur elle a une
tête de vieilles mais au naturel
[Applaudissements]
nos autres invités ce soit sont deux ils
sont bruns heureusement ils font de
l'humour sinon on aurait eu les frérots
delavega c'est le pole man show
[Applaudissements]
des centaines de sièges des dizaines de
parodies trois émissions spéciales sur
ces huit conca retenait alors certes
c'est pas évident a dû hausser une
mécanique bien précises c'est universel
il faut le clown blanc et l'auguste tu
vois c'est un mec normal et un gros
débile regard des cheveux laurel et
hardy naulleau et zemmour c'est toujours
la même antienne bien précise l'auteur
voilà la règle du no c'est
malheureusement il y en a toujours un
qui pètent plus que l'autre cela
convient omar et fred eric et ramzy de
caunes garcia
bon déjà c'est bien qu'ils en aient au
moins qui reste voix des fois c'est les
deux qui disparaissent fait un gros
bisou à charlie lui
[Applaudissements]
après avoir parlé relooking et humour
c'est celui qui va bien nous chez
l'ambiance ce soir c'est ma très vive
marche de l'unique ancien juge anti
terroriste osé connu plein de terrorisme
jeunes avant qu'ils commettent l'odieux
attentat c'est un peu le jacques martin
de neige
[Rires]
donc malheureusement c'est pas le papa
qui filmait aucun lescop mais bfm tv ça
j'aurais tellement voulu vous voir au
tribunal vous auriez pu utiliser les
mêmes méthodes que thierry c'est vrai au
sampler t'imagines
alors lequel d'entre vous est celui
qu'on appelait
si vous êtes là c'est qu'a priori tout
ne s'est pas passé comme prévu alors
lequel d'entre vous voulez
ces bons messieurs ce sera
oui
[Musique]
elle est barrée blue du vent
mais ça
ça aura été bien
[Applaudissements]
mais n'a donné cieux je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu déposer
messieurs du palmashow avec votre film
c'est une comédie d'aventuré sur fond de
guerre du goût pour reconstituer la
france sous l'occupation allemande vous
avez tourné à béziers
n'a hésité et d'hésitations marc
trévidic marc vous avez dit il faut être
très dur envers les multirécidivistes
justement quelles sanctions vous
donneriez à w9 qui récidive depuis cinq
ans avec les ch'tis
[Applaudissements]
je suis contre la censure et pour
terminer cristina cordula ans christina
c'est quoi le meilleurs conseils mode a
donné une brésilienne si les couilles
des passes de la jupe c'est qu'elle est
trop pop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ici là
et on passe maintenant à neutre théo tap
[Musique]
cristina cordula rabon soir
alors christina je vous propose qu'on
commence cette émission en tordant le
cou à une rumeur une rumeur insistante
sur les réseaux sociaux ces derniers
temps vous ne seriez pas brésilienne
vous seriez originaire de dijon vous
appelleriez christine corps tulle 1
toute cette histoire serait du marketing
les preuves s'accumulent à commencer par
le fait que vous n'ayez pas de pomme
d'adam et une brésilienne cependant
encore jamais vu ça en fait la vérité
c'est que vous n'avez pas d'accent au
départ et que vous essayez de prendre
cet accent brésilien mais j'y arrive et
il faut dire en fait vous parlez
parfaitement le français et vous donner
beaucoup de mal pour ne pas le perdre
chez rhodia
il vaut mieux un anorak et eu d'orage
c'est plus moi c'est mieux
c'est quoi le dicton un choix qui est
deux tu l'auras pas acquis 12 jours à
valras et saha à
mon dieu
julie elle est complètement à côté de la
pompe
mais quoi clermont ne me mêle pas de tes
oignons ma chérie
comme ça
christine déteste cette chanson elle
déteste la bossa nova le football elle
est est tous ces trucs à arrêter l est
pas du tout brésilienne dts les
telenovelas
le problème c'est que maintenant vous
n'arrivez plus à redevenir française
pensait voile plus ils disent que tant
que vous n'arriverez pas à dire
magnifique vous ne serez pas française
alors on va essayer allez-y magnifique
magnifique
magnifique magnifique chez eux
ma
dernière et c'est magnifique magnifique
la
[Musique]
manif
des jo alors christine corde il vous est
la règle
j'avoue que c'est bizarre christine
corday vous êtes la reine du relooking
c'est la campagne présidentielle on dit
que j'allais relooké alain juppé pour en
faire un mètre de gauche qui est le stan
smith et le quinoa qu'est ce que vous
allez faire avec alain juppé
ah ouais ouais ça vous inspire pas je
sais même pas comment je peux faire
parce qu'il a tellement déjà son esprit
assez classique un pull sur les épaules
de moelle osseuse oui mais on essaie
mais après faut pas trop décontracté non
plus ça va le faire marc trévidic qui
est l'acte un rockeur en fait marc
trévidic s'est pas du tout un juge
antiterroriste
vous pensez quoi d'une veste en daim
frange avec des santiag car ça va pas du
tout voilà justement alain juppé aussi
avec le trop décontracté ça va pas vous
ça va pas vous êtes une personne un
voile intégral
des soins possibles on vous voit en
train de parler des affaires qui sont
très sérieux mais peut-être jean le week
end je vous vois bien mais un jean avec
le plie repasser comme les patrons mais
aussi salades etc alors non c'est pas
comme la c1 ginga
justement ça alors vous avez vu
christine
ils sont lookés pour vous les deux là du
palmashow fantasy j'aime pas de produire
les gaves
et la classe
avec la veste chemise bien dépasser les
chaussures on adore la chaussette noire
vous tout au noir
ça va très bien les chaussures montantes
honnêtement la barbe bien taillée les
cheveux l'arrière honnêtement ça me va
très bien bon ben voilà c'est habillée
pour l'hiver
- piscines en j'arrive sur 6,8 connaît
ainsi une chaîne un peu de jeunes est ce
que je devrais rester comme ça où mettre
un sweat à capuche
[Rires]
avec vous a pas dit non non je reste
comme ça
ben moi j'ai pensé à mon pourriez me
relooké puis je suis tombé sur cette
photo de vous et là c'est quoi vous avez
perdu un pari mais c'est quoi cette
photo la mettais ma photo je suis bien
je sais
c'était pour vous retrouver si vous
étiez perdu en mer
les mélanges les imprimés elle était si
jolie séjour ya la lune pour laquelle il
ya aucun espoir c'est elle la si vous
arriviez à la relooker la carnation
qu'est ce qu'est le mal sapés poèmes de
blé
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour elle
condamne
elle est nue l'inflation dirait un
coffre à bijoux de
tête une très jolie femme au visage elle
est
naturellement que le côté nature alors
j'ai vu que cet été vous aviez pris
position contre le burqini clé steam
la christine qui prend position contre
le burkina c'est où ça m'a fait en
vacances les gens
n'ont pas du tout c'est un corse encore
c'est très joli et très bien à julien
doré a fait la même chose
[Musique]
alors christine vous animé avec succès
les rênes du shopping du lundi au
vendredi à 17h20 sur m6 et puis la
russie nouveau look pour une nouvelle
vie vous animé avec succès depuis 12 ans
un big up
[Musique]
on regarde à quoi cela semble
aujourd'hui dans new style new look
c'est au tour de sébastien de clermont
ferrand de se faire relooker qu'est ce
que vous pensez du look de seb le jeune
homme là où on c'est dur ça fait tout
elle est bonne quand même non oui là le
jeune homme a le chinois
salut je m'appelle sel gemme clermont
ferrand vient d'arriver à paris je
connais pas grand monde du pad coquine
donc voilà je voudrais changer de look
pour me sentir mieux dans ma nouvelle
vie quoi
souffert ce grand jour alors fini d'être
moche moche c'est pas moi c'est mon
style à
des quotas est géniale à diam's et kevin
[Musique]
et si
kevin est faible kevin et moi c'est que
ben c'est pas ici c'est comme steve
nouveau verveine ou un joli pull de
laine hockey superbe but kevin je vous
laisse à tout c'est que ben ça va c'est
vie ça va alors tu veux devenir un vrai
parisien bah ouais ok j'ai ce qu'il faut
mon coco common ma biche le viol
une heure plus tard c'est radical
sébastien et métamorphose est alors cbi
comment te sens tu bats je suis pas trop
c'est pas moi quoi tout bizarre c'est ce
qu'on va faire on se donne rendez vous
dans trois mois est en soi un checkpoint
hockey à l'exil
[Applaudissements]
christine parler
ça c'est le palmashow quand ils font pas
de cinéma après on parlera du palmashow
cinéma mais c'est déjà extraordinaire
franchement j'aime beaucoup voient mon
band
sais pas quoi dire merci et les publier
mon look book aux éditions larousse est
ce que depuis le temps que vous publiez
chez larousse ils ont offert un
dictionnaire
[Rires]
bon dans ce lit vous présenter les 30
basiques dont aucune femme ne peut se
passer marinière trench pantalon noir
jupe en cuir string mais qu'avec du ring
vous déclinez donc c'est basique en
trois looks différents le look urbain
pour tous les jours l'escapade pour le
week-end et night pour le soir voilà
parce que je peux parler maintenant
c'est maintenant ou jamais
non parce que en fait je me suis aperçu
qu on parle j'ai déjà beaucoup parlé de
nouveaux faux logis pas mes niveaux
précédents par les émissions des jo qui
dit on le trouve à laon v bon connaît sa
part qu'un morceau de j mais j'espère
que vous avez commencé j'ai pas mal
parlé aussi des basiques on connaît tous
les basiques de la garde robe mais en
fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'ils les
gens venaient me parler c'est que sinon
je connais ma mofo g koné l'étranger
comme sur les gens oui avec hainard
religieux comme ça dans ma chérie j'ai
c'est comme ça qu'on parc machines et je
tenais ma mort faut je vais basique mais
je n'arrive pas à les mélanger est
triste al comment ça se fait parce que
tu sais pas mélanger machine donc du
coup je prends ces basiques je décline
en look différent c'est à dire qu'avec
une pièce on peut aller on peut sortir
le soir on peut être un week end on peut
travailler et donc ça donne plein
d'idées de décliner ses basiques là et
être est ce pas l j'ai déjà numéro 1 sur
amazon exactement
non plus surpris dans la liste des
basiques ya le jogging aussi justement
parce qu'il faut moderniser et le
jogging aujourd'hui on voit donc plein
comme un plan des boutiques sont pas et
si on mélange avec une veste en parle
cuir un petit veste en jean ça peut être
un look pour voyager voyager et que ton
à 12 heures d'avion oui et les bas de
contention
gérer cela fait très sympa alors il a
une qui portent mal le jogging a quand
même un oui alors voilà y'a la tendance
jogging et agricole mais là le problème
c'est le haut qui est un peu trop on
n'avait pas besoin de
changement toutes ces histoires de
mélange c'est quand jean paul gaultier
mais le mec a mis des tutus avec des
perfectos c'est jean paul gaultier fait
avec merveille voilà c'est comme lui a
inventé ça je vous le directement et
parce que mélanger les choses
quand c'est mal fait c'est la
catastrophe il sait faire à merveille et
je suis ravi qu'il acceptait de venir
faire un special guest dans les rênes de
shopping alors disons que je me
suis demandé si par amour vous
accepteriez de souvenirs l'esclave
sexuelle de votre mec on regarde comment
ça s'est passé
la question et non la moindre est ce que
par amour regardez moi bien christina
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
pourquoi pas lui sérieux je suis ton
esclave sexuelle
ça c'est la télévision il paraît qu
ensuite je vais un peu rechigner ça veut
dire quoi racing et rechigné à l'édition
complète de moitié ne s'est pas encore
signé
des contrats portugais
c'est bien c'est laurent mendy et donc
non pas dire chine c'est bien que vous
êtes rentré à la maison vous n'avez pas
vraiment voulu être son esclave sexuelle
donc là ce soir vous allez le juré on va
faire la question sous serment
et
chérie
je te jure d'être ton esclave sexuel ce
soir dites-le
cgt jure d'être ton esclave sexuel ce
soir bon ben voilà
c'est arrivé pour aller me sens mieux
après une réponse car elle va pas rester
trop longtemps dans le noir non plus
donc j'ai très bien bravo donc à et
j'espère que ça se passera mieux parce
que quand même canton premier quelque
chose on n'est pas obligé de le faire
mais quand on le jure comme vous venez
de le juré mais moi j'ai cette femme des
paroles je m'attends à un jeu ou quoi ah
oui évidemment que quand un jeu est oui
c'est mon ami guillaume qui m'a fait des
photos formidable alors tout le monde
joue un demi point par demi bonne
réponse on a mélangé deux styles deux
styles il faut que tu dises les deux
personnes que tu retrouves les deux
styles
ça c'est zemmour oui c'est du carton
ces mots et qui même bord politique
marion mazzano mois de 2009
elle continue
[Applaudissements]
ses bienfaits
christine boutin et oui les gens
marmande une bravo on y parle
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable et peur
j'en étais plus que les pentes sasserno
dans oui c'est renoncer fignon fillon et
relais renaud roy
[Applaudissements]
a préféré
comment s'appelle de m'acquitter
s'appelle guillaume il est très très
fort il a ainsi qu'il est sur twitter il
a fait un livre il est s ingénient
singer nul
et martine aubry
françois hollande et mme versailles
marine la donne si nous
continuons à
le palmashow largement douay
[Applaudissements]
c'est un super
gars oui ça
c'est le meilleur l'étape c'est là où là
c'est moi
gecina oui
dernière
cette dernière pour la route on
ya gagné qui a daigné palmashow le pas
macho
encore un succès
[Applaudissements]
et
voilà c'est une affaire dès cet été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais mon champ l'intérieur annonçant
les terriens
certains toujours en compagnie de crise
inattendue l'ère
de marc rich
du palmashow
et on passe maintenant à notre interview
tété ou de la semaine
c
t t au à lille
rebond soir marc trévidic on sera
[Applaudissements]
alors non on a tous en tête les propos
du président la république au sujet de
la magistrature
cette institution est une institution de
l'acheter parce que c'est quand même ça
tousse et procureurs tous ces hauts
magistrats
on se planque on joue les vertueux on
n'aime pas le politique la justice
n'aime pas le politique vous savez à
quoi vous en tenir maintenant le
président ne vous aime pas oui ma faim
c'est un peu réciproque c'est vrai qu'on
n'aime pas trop les politiques non plus
mais je crois qu'il a une mauvaise idée
parce que les magistrats qui voit ses
les courtisans ouais on voit pas les
magistrats qui travaillent ce qu'ils
pensent fatalement c'est tous les
présidents ce problème ils sont entourés
par une cour y compris de hauts
magistrats donc il n'a pas d'idée ce que
de ce que feront les juges ordinaires
dans tous les cas donné un juge déjà ça
gagne pas beaucoup de blé il faut dire
la vérité
un mal de chien fait que blake un peu on
peut pas non mais c'est vrai quand même
bien et du mal vous buzz et gagnez pas
beaucoup et à la sortie vous êtes traité
très mal quand même c'est vrai que c'est
l'institution elle même est une
institution qui remplit pas son rôle
suffisamment c'est vrai que c'est une
institution qui est un peu au service de
l'exécutif c'est une tradition très
française on n'a pas de vraie séparation
des pouvoirs on n'a pas un vrai poids
dans la société
donc si vous dites l'ag qui n'a pas
tellement tort il n'a pas complètement
tort il faudrait arriver à ce qu'on
coupe le cordon avec avec le pouvoir
exécutif et que les gens et du courage
qu'ils attendent pas des ânes avancement
le fait du prince donc on a une
institution qui est basé sur une
soumission là où il a tort dire que de
ma vie sera enfin l'a dit l'institution
la plupart des juges moque de sa font
bien leur travail général le parquet en
a rien à cirer
ça m'est venu comme ça celui-ci explique
quand même un petit peu le mépris avec
lequel j'ai été exilé à lille bien sûr
il ya la règle des dix ans un juge ne
peut pas rester dix ans au même endroit
enfin il ya quand même une exception qui
aurait pu être fait pour le meilleur
juge antiterroriste de france
les exceptions c'est difficile vous
pouvez pas parler de mon cas il ya des
bons juges antiterroristes il faut pas
croire parce qu'ils sont pas médiatiques
qui en a pas qu'il y en a jamais eu
autant besoin de vous de maintenant là
c'est un autre problème c'est
qu'effectivement il ya toute façon à un
sou nombre et que c'est un peu dommage
que linux et la matière aujourd'hui vous
êtes vice président du tribunal de
grande instance de lille chargé des
affaires familiales comment tu dois te
faire chier ouais mais ça rigole pas
bientôt vous serez qualifié
de djihadiste qui veulent divorcer
alors est le meilleur qui aura la garde
des explosifs parfois c'est ça
[Musique]
le mot
dès qu ils ont dans les yeux bleus qui
manque à leur décor les gens du nord
mais plus en plus elle pouvait plus du
maroilles
échos maroilles quartino maroilles salah
de maroilles magret au maroilles ils ont
mettre partout de la rue ils sont à doha
franchement d'une orgie mais c'est vrai
que marwa j'ai du mal à vous dites je
suis un exil et géographique
[Musique]
d'ailleurs j'aime exilés géographique je
suis à lille sans ma femme et mes
enfants
ça fragilise psychologiquement quand
même oui vous êtes dans un petit
appartement tout seul dans mon petit
studio ses classes à paris non non
on voit les plus beaux moments plus
fâché voile week-end alors qu'il était
en même temps j'ai le temps d'occuper
mes soirées à écrire votre dernier livre
à la main s'est très bien vendu oui
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai que le
nord canton n'est pas le collier qu'on
bouge pas et que sa soeur on cherche
encore fait il est dit que quand même il
ya dès lors du sac et puis on la musique
[Applaudissements]
je pose ma vie a lancé des musiques ya
des gens qu'on vit des tweets en disant
qu'ils en avaient marre ils ont raison
on va regarder la musique
[Musique]
j'me jane marc trévidic cherche au
plateau dominique holtzer ni comment
elles comment la recherche
alors revenons à l'actualité j'ai
déclaré on a dix années dures à passer
veut dire que françois hollande brill de
se faire élire deux fois c'est ça
mais disent vous êtes gentils parce que
pourquoi 10 bah c'est à dire par rapport
à ce qu'on vit actuellement on now on a
deux trois ans de retour de djihadistes
4 5 ans allait gérer tous ceux qui vont
rentrer en europe partout ça va
commencer avec la taxe sur mossoul matin
qu'il m'avait cessa servir plus l'état
islamique va s'effondrer plus ils vont
revenir ici en fait assez la tumeur
centrale il y en a plein qui vont jamais
testé un peu partout pensez quoi de
l'idée d'en fermer les fichiers s
derrière des barbelés surveillés par des
miradors moi je reste influent qu'il
faut des preuves pour pour incarcérer
les gens il faut des juges aussi vous
dites c'est ce que veut des jeux en fait
c'est que on les met dans des camps de
façon à faire monter la pression et crée
la guerre civile en fait bah c'est leur
seule stratégie possible terroriste
effort parce qu'il arrive à recruter dès
qu'un groupe ne recrute plus il est mort
donc leur stratégie ces caisses qui va
faire que des jeunes musulmans vont
venir vers nous mais ça ne peut être que
notre action à nous si on sûr réagi et
comprend des mesures injustes et
proportionnée à différencier sur tous
les gens qui sont aux gens vont
effectivement croire qu'on islamophobe
croire qu'on en veut à l'islam et ils
vont rejoindre ils vont rejoindre dèche
mais il y a pas de solution à court
terme il y en a plus à court terme il
faut maintenant éviter que
la prochaine génération ce radicalisme
pratiquement on peut éviter que la
prochaine vous vous les prenez vous
prenez des jeunes qui ne sont pas
radicaliser qu'on 12 13 ans et il faut
s'adresser à eux faut leur expliquer les
dangers d'une religion fondamentalistes
la violence eux ils ont sont ouverts ils
ont l'esprit ouvert puisqu'ils sont pas
radicaliser mais il faut que quand ils
auront 14 15 ans 16 ans il ya un copain
et 7 de leur en donné versa il est des
défenses immunitaires vous voyez faut
vraiment ciblé au niveau d'éducation
d'information
bah oui c'est un peu comme la broque
faut commencer avec ceux qui n'ont
jamais plus en lisant faut que jamais
que tu en prennes alors le pire est il
toujours sûr on va faire une interview
pire express
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors marc trévidic la pire journée de
votre vie c'est à égalité absolue la
mort de mon père et de ma mère la pire
personne pour diriger la france ce
qu'ils ont déjà fait au son moto
et un petit rigole de votre jeunesse a
cessé et babar
parce que babar m'a fait croire qu'un
homme politique un dirigeant pouvait
être honnête juste droit à les protéger
c'était des conneries c'est la chaussure
noël
le pire truc que vous ayez vu à lille
des parents qui veulent pas de leurs
enfants ni l'un ni l'autre il ya un
endroit où on peut les laisser parce que
ça m'intéresse
la pire fonction que vous ayez occupé
marque la pire c'est quand même la
huitième section c'était un section des
crimes et délits flagrants ouais c'était
les comparutions immédiates jusqu'à une
heure du matin les crimes la nuit donc
réveillés la nuit près comment toutes
les nuits pour avoir des
kadhafistes 97 à 99 la pire émission
vous avez été invité au grand journal
parce que on m'avait dit que natalie
portman était invité je suis arrivé
était pas invitée
j'ai pas pensé je sais pas ce qui a été
fait exprès ou pas mais mes gardes du
corps aussi été père déçu le pire cadeau
qu'on vous ait fait un briquet parce que
je venais d'arrêter de fumer je voulais
faire la surprise à mes parents ils
offrent un briquet
le champignac loupé la pire question
qu'on vous est posée en suisse et c'est
toujours est-ce que j'ai peur d'être
rebutés par les islamistes la question
qui voilà vous avez combien de gardes du
corps voilà je ne réponds pas à ces
questions là justement
j'ai aussi con que les autres biens
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant à la provo de blacko
attention images chocs
la principale différence entre des shs
et l'arabie saoudite c'est la couleur
des vêtements les saoudiens s'habillent
en blanc les djihadistes en noir mais
pour le reste il a pris la charia
exactement de la même manière
on s'indigne de la barbarie des ch m
c'est pareil en arabie saoudite
on y décapite en place publique les
meurtriers les homosexuels et ceux qui
blasphème
ronnie lapide les femmes en cas
d'adultère
quant au voleur on se contente de leur
couper les mains
sinon vous avez le cas du jeune ali al
ni mire après avoir participé à une
manifestation contre le pouvoir il a été
condamné être décapités puis crucifié en
place publique pour que son corps
pourrissent aux yeux de tous en fête
vais-je et l'arabie saoudite partagent
la même idéologie totalitaire du coup
l'hypocrisie de la france est flagrante
y a qu'à écouter manuel valls passe à ce
totalitarisme islamiste la france mène
et mènera une guerre implacable ah ah la
bonne blague au contraire la france
déroule le tapis rouge saoudien notre
président a même remis la légion
d'honneur alors ministre de l'intérieur
alors bien sûr il ya la realpolitik les
saoudiens ont le pétrole et les dollars
qui vont avec est-ce qu'il n'est pas
indécent de se réjouir de la signature
de contrats commerciaux avec l'arabie
saoudite un pays qui a exécuté 134
personnes franchement indécent de se
battre pour notre économie pour nos
industries pour nos emplois et pas
seulement avec un lycée ou 10 alors mais
pourquoi la france a refusé de vendre
des frégates à la russie alors qu'elle
rêve de vendre des rafale ou des chars
leclerc aux saoudiens d'ici quelques
années des cht aura vaincu comme l'a été
elle qaïda mais la réponse militaire ne
suffit pas il faut aussi lutter contre
ceux qui propagent l'idéologie réaliste
il faut se poser la question pourquoi
djihadistes en ces idées-là et d'où
vient-elle parce que ses idées sont
soutenus par des puissances par des
états comme l'arabie saoudite qui
finance alors à quoi ça sert de
combattre des jld si on soutient
l'arabie saoudite qui dépensent des
milliards chaque année pour répandre
l'islam intégriste à travers le monde
voilà pour le blaco nous à l'image de
julien gracq merci alexandre delval
bonsoir
je consulte enjeux politiques et les
publier les vrais ennemis de l'occident
aux éditions de l'artilleur bienvenue
parmi nous alors alexandre bullet
l'islamisme radical s'est pas seulement
al qaïda aidé à esch mais des états amis
de la france les monarchies du golfe
mais aussi la turquie ce qui représente
quand même une menace beaucoup plus
sournoise tout cela vient de la guerre
froide pendant la guerre froide on a
élaboré au sein de l'otan la stratégie
de la muslim belt il fallait empêcher la
russie d'accéder aux mers chaudes par la
constitution d'une chaîne d'état si
possible islamistes radicaux puisque
l'ennemi étant le communisme les plus
anti communiste n'était pas kamel daoud
où les musulmans la xt plutôt les
islamistes et malheureusement après la
chute de l'ex urss cette stratégie a été
continu et en bosnie au kosovo en irak
où on a démantelé un état laïque au
profit d' islamiste à la fois chiites et
sunnites tout le monde en avait pour son
compte on a continué sa en libye et
entre temps je ne parle même pas des
frères musulmans qui ont été sponsorisés
pratiquement partout les états
occidentaux
sans oublier la france qui a micro mini
au pouvoir alors que l'avion gare destin
l'avion du huard et régler le compte en
avion oui on sait explique pourquoi on
est ami avec l'arabie saoudite le qatar
et tous ces gens là et pas avec poutine
alors que si on devait se défendre de
ces gens là poutine serait quand même un
allié naturel même si son régime n'est
pas exempt de critiques il ya énormément
de l'exagération à propos de ce qui se
passe en russie parce que justement nous
sommes toujours quelque part en guerre
froide s'est récemment les dirigeants
américains obama lui-même où hillary
clinton on dit que la russie était un
danger plus grave que des shs y voilà
des gens qui pensent que la russie est
plus dangereuse que ceux qui viennent
égorgés ou tués enfant sur nos terrasses
alors marc trévidic vous dit lutter
contre l'islam radical tout en serrant
la main du roi d'arabie saoudite revient
à dire que nous luttons contre le
nazisme tout en invitant éclairent notre
table oui oui ça je dis ça y est déjà
quelques temps c'est tellement une
évidence cela est une évidence mais on
continue quand même à s'y reprend à la
base le salafiste d'aujourd'hui y
compris dans sa version la plus la plus
rigoureuse ces câbles le produit d'année
d'années de diffusion du wahhabisme sur
la planète jeu tout à fait d'accord et
en plus il faut rappeler que 75
milliards de dollars 60 5 milliards
d'euros ont été dépensés depuis les 1980
par la seule arabie saoudite kilic qui
n'est que l'un des cinq pôles de
l'islamisme radical c'est à dire on n'a
jamais vu un financement aussi
extraordinaire aussi planétaire aussi 75
milliards de dollars des chiffres
sérieuse et à l'indépendance et le
salafisme dans le monde on n'a jamais
mis autant d'argent dans le financement
de aucune propagande que ça soit le
nazisme le communisme jamais un
totalitarisme n'a disposé d'autant de
moyens financiers et c'est pour ça que
regarder le mali on avait un islam très
tolérants au mali imbibé de deux
traditions africaines aujourd'hui le
chef de l'islam officielle à bamako on
est quelqu'un qui était formée par les
saoudiens et qui a même défendu à
plusieurs reprises les djihadistes au
nord-mali quand la france alors départ
le gouvernement ne restions à quoi sont
utilisés ces 75 milliards c'est-à-dire
il ya ce qu'on appelle le soft power
c'est à dire ils nous font la guerre par
des chevaux violemment mais eux ils
rachètent le psg quoi c'est une guerre
idéologique
c'est pour ça que moi je dis le
terrorisme n'est pas l'ennemi le
terrorisme c'est un moyen d'action c'est
un mode opératoire de type militaire
enfin guerrier ce qui est le véritable
ennemi c'est une entité vivante organisé
c'est lénine avait dit les capitalistes
nous vendrons la corde pour les pendre
oui nous c'est exactement ce qu'on fait
je suis tout à fait d'accord non
seulement nous trahissons nos propres
valeurs mais en plus nous trahissons
même nos immigrés musulmans parce que
confier nos concitoyens musulmans à ceux
qui ont porte pour programme de ne pas
les intégrer parce que pour
l'intégration c'est l'intégration à la
mécréance moi j'ai retrouvé tous leurs
textes dans mon livre que que je cite et
ils disent explicitement qu'il ne faut
absolument pas un graissez gens parce
qu' il deviendra en quelque sorte un pur
donc on a confié la gestion de l'islam
en europe est ce pas que nous pas que la
france tous les pays occidentaux aux
grands pôles de l'islamisme radical à
commencer par l'arabie saoudite la ligue
islamique mondiale l'organisation de la
coopération islamique etc enfin tous ses
pôles de l'islamisme radical qui ont un
projet non seulement de non intégration
mais de conquête du monde se sont vu
confier la gestion c'est une démarche
néo impérial c'est une démarche neo
xperia impérial mais facilitée par les
anciens impérialiste et novès politiques
font croire qu'ils ne savent pas mais
leur serre les mains les mêmes qui
insultent poutine et qui disent qu'il
faut faire et le faire passer devant un
tribunal pénal international les mêmes
reçoivent à tour avec les halls et il le
sait ça hollande mais le sait
parfaitement c'est très très grave parce
que ça veut dire que si valls hollande
pour parler que d'eux évidemment c'est
ceux qui sont au pouvoir aujourd'hui
s'ils savent ça s'ils ont les preuves
que vous apportez dans l'autre leader
qui était comme ça oui s'ils savent ça
et qu'ils continuent alors parlé à
discuter avec eux elle considérait pas
comme des ennemis ils trahissent la
france mais bien sûr la france et les
valeurs de l'occident et les valeurs de
démocratie que j'ai appelé société
ouverte de mon livre et c'est pour ça
que quand j'avais à peine 30 ans j'ai
quitté le secrétariat général à la
défense nationale nous faisions des
notes sur les nouvelles menaces à
l'époque les salafistes n'était pas
encore de nationalité française il avait
ri qu'ils arrivaient directement de
médine et mon supérieur me disais ça
sert à rien nos hommes politiques se
contrefiche il faut qu'ils aient un
grand événement un sommet un mondial
pour qu'ils arrêtent ces gens mais en
fait finalement ils ont ils ont accepté
que des néo impérialistes finalement
saisissent nos territoires et s'immisce
dans nos affaires et empêche
l'intégration de nos concitoyens alors
quand on dit sarkozy a vendu la france
au qatar se veut dire quoi sic déjà le
qatar ils payent pas de plus value sur
les reventes oui il ya eu les achète un
immeuble ils le revendent ils payent pas
de plus value alors que nous le pauvre
appartement qu on vraiment dans une plus
value il a eu beaucoup d'accords fiscaux
avec d'autres pays aussi il faut le dire
alors les uns c'était le qatar hollande
c'est l'arabie saoudite a trait à ses
deux carry blanche il l'avait donc de
dents dans tous les cas nos hommes
politiques de gauche comme de droite
reste compromis mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut couper les liens avec ces
pays moi je ne dis pas qu'il faut faire
la guerre avec ces pays il faudrait
juste les responsabiliser peut-être
qu'ils ne vous plaisait pas mais un jour
1 un homme que j'ai connus qui
s'appelait charles pasqua qui n'est pas
énarque qui m'avait dit moi comme je
suis pas énarque j'ai la chance d'avoir
un peu de bon sens mon homologue
saoudien je lui avais dit est ce que tu
aimerais que je finance des églises chez
toi il m'a répondu non alors je lui dit
arrête de financer des mosquées chez moi
alors
l'arabie saoudite a installé à
mantes-la-jolie dans les yvelines le
bureau de la ligue islamiste mondial
trois mille mètres carrés oui et le
savez pas tout ça elle est le siège et
le siège au niveau mondial à bruxelles
alors cette ligue islamique mondiale
elle est très intéressante elle a pour
but explicite de répandre le vrai islam
salafiste wahhabite au sein des
populations immigrées musulmane et
d'empêcher toute intégration aux valeurs
impie et c'est en plus on a même des
textes où c'est écrit noir sur blanc
alors est-ce que bientôt vous pensez
qu'il y aura un parti politique
islamique en france financé par l'arabie
saoudite ou le qatar comme c'est déjà le
cas en belgique avec le parti nur non
ils sont trop intelligents pense là les
puissances islamistes et aussi les
frères musulmans comme un l'un de leurs
guides qardaoui disent c'est trop tôt
pour l'instant il faut déjà répandre une
paranoïa afin de préparer à une sorte de
sécession une partition avec l'argument
de l'islamophobie faire croire à tous
les musulmans de france que tous les
français d'ailleurs d'origine ou pas les
déteste et ça c'est très serré c'est
assez habile vous êtes d'accord avec ça
mais bien tout à fait et je bois du
petit lait j'allais dire et je voudrais
prendre l'exemple du canada peut-être
que vous connaissez en 2003 ils ont
failli ils ont été à ça
de d'accepter que la charia en matière
civile havas pénale soit soit appliquée
c'est à dire que la communauté musulmane
ne applique la charia matière si
notamment pour tout ce qui est
répudiation jeux propres aux juges et à
ce moment là mais oui c'est à dire en
fait l'argument était de dire toute
façon les femmes musulmanes ne vont pas
aller voir le juge laïque mécréants
parce qu'ils peuvent pas ses comptes la
région donc il vaut mieux qu'elle est
quand même un minimum de tribunaux donc
on va accepter les tribunaux islamiques
jusqu'au mois il y aura quand même un
minimum donc c'est une sorte de
partition si on commence à faire des
choses comme ça un marc trévidic vous
avez déclaré la religion n'est pas le
moteur du jihad le moteur du djihad
c'est finalement ce que vous dit
alexandre le projet totalitaire il y un
projet totalitaire qui explicitement
dans de nombreux textes de nombreux pays
organisations expliquent qu'il faut un
jour envahir l'europe pour vous donner
un exemple le monsieur qui est le
président de la formation des imams
européen à château-chinon territoire qui
avaient été donnés pas pour un euro
symbolique par monsieur mitterrand on y
enseigne que le but c'est d'islamiser
l'europe et qardaoui aaa il a sorti tout
cela en disant mais cette fois ci ce ne
sera pas forcément par le sabre des taux
courants oui bien sûr je passais le très
connu et il y en a eu beaucoup de
difficulté j'irai à pouvoir avoir des
éléments sur des gens qui étaient passés
par là et qui ont mal tourné
oui c'est moi qu'on plaisir mais surtout
c'est il ya deux méthodes gamme étant un
peu politique frères musulmans on
accepterait de jouer les jeux politiques
pour prendre le pouvoir il ya la méthode
vraiment des salafistes plus values
requis qui veulent pas se mélanger la
démocratie qu'ils utilisent la violence
en fait c'est ça mais le but final c'est
la charia dans les deux cas ils sont
logiques avait quand même oui ils sont
en cohérence avec leurs valeurs les
vrais responsables sont nos dirigeants
qui vendent les teyrannais basilan
société avec son delval merci d'avoir
été dossier merci voilà ce que tu
appelles de celle t on se retrouve sur
terre après à tout prix
[Musique]
hamon sur l'éternel bon sens les
terriens nous sommes de retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie de cristina
cordula
de marc trévidic
machault et nous accueillons manuel
ferrara
manuel ferrara au soir soit comme vinh
bisel eminem ou rafael nadal vous avez
fait rêver tous les adolescents du monde
mais contrairement à eux vous êtes
toujours au top vous êtes encore
aujourd'hui l'acteur x le mieux payé de
la planète du hlm de gagny au palace
d'hollywood vous nous direz comment vous
avez dû coucher pour réussir
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant avant en l'honneur de
grégoire et david du palmashow affaire
que blindtest duo
[Musique]
attention tpr et naulleau des saints
peut gagner les autres des fois parce
que là l'ombre
avec les johnatan on va dire à lorient
envie de toi
oui cela reste
vigilante
[Applaudissements]
et d'une vous comptez les points dans le
cas un laurent
voilà qui a répondu je crois que c'est
david et johnatan ont répondu de
prométhée moi un petit peu le reveal pas
ce que c'est
c
[Applaudissements]
nostalgie quand tu nous tiens attention
non
bateau
[Musique]
mais dimanche avant ma cause magnifique
attention l'ombre
tout défi
attendez attendez là non parce que comme
lors on arrête de souffler parce
qu'elles n'arrivent même pas à répéter
ce que tu lui dis donc je préfère que tu
joues pour toi
parce que mehamha quelqu'un que je
connaissais déjà mais je positive pas
christian il est très fort
attention l'ombre
[Musique]
ma carioca les stars notamment et java
oh
c'est bien
spéciale dédicace alain chabat tu ne
regardes attention lambres
un fascicule 0
[Musique]
il
non très très bon ah c'est la relève
chez les jeunes non mais c'est d'accord
ils sont bons entièrement d'accord tiens
si vous arrivez à battre laurent blind
test les mecs double promo aller way est
double peiné
attention nombre
david et jonathan oui la visite de la
tombe bien
je suis
objet de tous côtés donc
lambres
[Musique]
hélas
m
[Musique]
selon cheikh sinan al qattan à 15 heures
[Applaudissements]
à tina turner
oui tu as gagné un point à hilton le
point sur
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
michael jackson
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je suis impressionné là j'ai mangé bien
arrête et cuits à la base''
alain rigaud j'ai larigot
tony chapron
[Musique]
toi
l'ombre
[Musique]
bon bien gagner
palmashow way
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
valorise enfants merci attention on
passe maintenant à notre deuxième tu es
au top de la semaine
[Musique]
grégoire ludig et david marsais bonsoir
vous avez été des pionniers sur cette
chaîne vous avez connu direct 8 j'ai
commencé avec morandini oui ce qui
devient
regarde pas la télé
bien connue des 8 oui oui maintenant si
vite ouais à un moment on a dit que vous
partiez sur tf1 c'est vrai que c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai nom ce sera sur
equidia ouais
alors il ya trois semaines la folle
soirée du palmashow numéro 3 a cartonné
je vous ai fait 1,3 million sur la tnt
c'est très très bien et aujourd'hui vous
revenez avec un film intitulé la folle
histoire de max et leon le problème si
vous avez fait beaucoup d'émissions
avant de faire celle-là vous avez fait
touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
c'est la fin de match et ils adorent ça
règle qui chouchou les petites boutiques
sont contents et plein mais oui oui bah
oui très content d'être là pour parler
du film justement ça raconte génial mais
d'abord on se fait les quatre quarts à
jean-luc jean-luc kg champion fêté
quatre coeurs car les quatre agents lui
alors oui alors ce cas drôle à un moment
c'était avec david pendant le film ah ça
c'est génial avait d'abord la semaine du
prêt
à tourner en belgique on aime à la
mairie achète le château en château
c'est à vous avec anne sophie lapix
avant de faire ça n'était rien pour
tromper dire que le gouvernement belge
n'a pas réussi à convaincre ses
concitoyens
voilà l'émission touche à sa fin
peut-être avant de se dire au revoir
d'autres mots sur votre film grégoire et
david
s'échangeait à 2
génial en tout cas ça donne envie
vieira s'est plaint ce qu il fait le
décompte du magnéto exmar là je veux
dire c'est bon aussi vous avez le grand
journal
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé cette
association contre la maladie de stephen
je comprends pas mon meilleur ami a
vraiment été très difficile
grégoire et david vous sortez votre film
la folie store de max et leon oui alors
en fait ben c'est l'histoire de deux
meilleures amies c'est important les
meilleures zones
bas donc qu'ils aiment bien faire la
fête ou si on adorait faire la fête
[Applaudissements]
c'est une histoire qui se déroule
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
manière de traiter les conflits actuels
vous pensez quoi des ch
c'est une histoire qui se déroule
pendant quatre années avec des
rebondissements des péripéties des
actions des rencontres vous êtes charlie
et donc c'est un film qui sort le 2
novembre
israël palestine
et même thalassa c'est pour dire
c'était hors supor au portage sur
l'épreuve de 100 kg camille claud bien
des crabes dans votre film non je crois
maintenant on fait souvent des badauds
mal tout de suite un reportage sur les
phares du finistère
[Musique]
l'avantagé ici c'est que personne ne
vous coupera la parole dont personne
n'est pas du genre à couper la parole en
la folle histoire de mac sont les gens
qui couple à
la folle histoire de me faire relooker
alors la folie un peu l'histoire de max
et les personnes ce cheveu la fin
d'histoire de mal c'est léon la règle
d'or
safin pour la pose des questions
c'est l'animateur non non c'est une
complicité
même pas besoin de se parler on s'écoute
jamais l'offre l'histoire de max et lyon
c'est un film important car pour la
première fois qu'on ménage rigole le
respect l arrête tu paraître alors non
sérieusement depuis les années 60 on ne
rigole plus avec la seconde guerre
mondiale parce qu'en fait avant il y la
grande vadrouille la 7ème compagnie papy
fait de la résistance etc et puis au
début des années 70 les gens grâce au
chagrin et la pitié se sont aperçu de ce
que les français aient fait pendant la
guerre et vous renouer avec la tradition
du film marron sur la deuxième guerre
mondiale ben oui on a en fait c'est ce
que vous avez dit non on est hyper
inspiré de tous ces films papy fait de
la résistance la grande vadrouille et on
les a regardés un milliard de fois quand
on était petits ces films là qui nous
ont donné envie de faire des sketchs
d'écrire un film et je pense qu'avec
david on avait envie de renouer donc
avec ses comédies d' aventure mais avec
une petite touche de modernité pouvoir
raconter un petit peu faire quelques
parallèles avant que focalisant un peu
sur les français justement alors le
pitch est l'histoire de deux amis
d'enfance qui tente par tous les moyens
d'échapper la deuxième guerre mondiale
ils sont prêts à tout pour sauver leur
peau parce qu'effectivement sont pas du
tout courage et c'est des vrais français
un ferry c'est ça exactement ben ouais
non mais on s'est posé la question
justement qu'est ce qui se passe si nous
demain on part à la guerre globalement
on a envie de se barrer ouais sauf que
ce soit à gagner
un moment il bat des soldats français
leur pique leurs uniformes ils sont
considérés comme des héros on les
retrouve à londres chez le général de
gaulle qu'il est fini il va raconter
tout le film et c'est très marrant
ensuite ils vont en syrie et là vous
avez découvert un truc c'est que la
syrie qu'était un protectorat français
depuis 1920 en fait pendant la guerre en
syrie il y avait les résistants qui se
battait contre les vichystes mais
d'après nos recherches de mende a
découvert ce passage l'opération xporter
justement last year était sous
protectorat
vichyste en fait et au moment où
ou la vichy commence à collaborer les
colonies dont la colonie syrienne
justement décide de se rallier à vichy
donc le général de gaulle kessé un
moment donné d'asseoir son autorité
essayer de récupérer les colonies et
embarque les anglais pour aller
récupérer damas et ça crée une guerre
civile dont parle pas du tout en fait
alors film historique avec comme des
thématiques moderne oui quel est le mec
c'est ces deux tanguy qui sont
complètement apolitique indifférence
avec eux lors leur simple but c'est
d'être chez eux à la guinguette à boire
des coups à être entre eux à se marrer
et tout ce qui est en dehors de chez eux
ça les intéresse pas ils savent pas est
en fait ils sont plutôt naïf et ignorant
plutôt que plutôt que purement qu'on en
fait ouais alors le mieux c'est de
regarder à quoi ça ressemblait à
rallonge et oui
les combines pour se réformer c'est quoi
tu sais ça toi maman
oui
cette compagnie bam filer droit
on l'aura soir et après fillon nous nous
sommes l'honneur de la france mais
croyez moi on va la gagner cette guerre
dr tim et vous ne pensez pas j'espère
vous envoie en syrie tout ce qui est
charpente une fois dans le désert de
damas sera la routine c'est grand et pas
dans la merde
on se fond dans damas pour ça j'attaque
le mur d'enceinte
et vous avez réussi à rejoindre londres
sont un commando à eux tous seuls des
cracks règles persan et cheval devenu
ridicule
voilà la feuille soir max et en passant
ça promet alors il ya deux choses
auxquelles je ne pensais pas parce que
vous êtes nuls en promo en fait
la première chose c'est que c'est pas
une accumulation de sketches c'est un
film on avait à coeur de justement de
passer des sketches à la télé au cinéma
et de ne pas ne serait-ce que prendre
nos personnages qu'on fait dans les
sketchs et de les étirer pendant une
année ça ça marche sur trois minutes
mais sur 1h30 ça casse la tête et même
on avait envie de nous deux nous
challenge est entre guillemets d'arrivée
c'est que là c'est un vrai film voilà
c'est un bref il ya du pognon radio du
bout des doigts là leur deuxième chose
que vous devriez dire mais bon c'est que
il ya des guest oui à commencer par kad
merad et florence foresti c'est pas rien
quand même vous me dire les mecs alors
dans le film il ya des guest
kad merad
ça c'est des bons
[Musique]
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs nous
passons un autre terriens du samedi soir
[Musique]
manuel ferrara rebond soir
vous êtes donc manuel l'acteur porno le
mieux payé de la planète
tout le monde vous connaît même si ce
soit personne veut dire qui vous a déjà
vu comme c'est normal alors vous êtes né
le 1er novembre 1975 au raincy sous le
nom de manuel janin père électricien
mère femme de ménage vous grandissez
dans une cité hlm à gagny à
l'adolescence vous êtes extrêmement
pudique un traître est publique à
l'époque je faisais du judo ouais
j'attendais que tout le monde passe à la
douche et sortent pour pouvoir moi
ensuite il ya les comme scénario en 1997
vous préparez une carte d'anniversaire
en découpant et en collant des photos
trouvées dans une revue porno achetée au
kiosque du coin est là
[Musique]
et oui vous découvrez une petite annonce
pour un casting ça s'appelait pourquoi
pas vous voilà c'était une révélation
c'est assez drôle aussi parce qu'à la
base j'avais pas acheter le magazine
c'était la mère d'une amie qui avait
acheté ce magazine en pensant que
c'était un magazine de casting
traditionnelle et pascal b avec un
fascicule qui s'appelait casting x elle
n'avait pas vu le x alors à partir de là
vous concilier vos cours à la fac de
sport avec votre vie de ardeurs
trois ans plus tard vous rencontrez
gabriel 0 wec qui n'a aucun lien de
parenté avec karl zéro est un
réalisateur de porno type la vérité si
tu bandes ils ont fait le film games ont
fait la vérité a sèchement que
[Rires]
gabriel cabré elle est aussi le trou san
rocco siffredi requis sac est dingue
c'est que gabriel le cousin de rocco
siffredi d'arauco vous prend sous son
aile brésilien
2 ans et 10 fine plus tard le
réalisateur américain john galliano vous
donne un deuxième rôle reco avait le
premier dans une super production ultra
célèbres qui s'appelle fashionista oui à
l'époque il il préparait la plus grosse
production porno aux états unis serco
qui vous recommande oui il dit au
réalisateur à johnny dit non seulement
il a une grosse [__] mais en plus de ça
il tient des heures ouais en fait c'est
souvent très exagérés lorsqu'ils disent
qu'ils tiennent contient des heures
c'est très souvent plus rapide que ça
mais le challenge c'était qu'à l'époque
je parlait pas très bien anglais la wii
ce bruit revient pas beaucoup de
dialogues
c'était surprenant est que l'otan c'est
vrai qu'ils sont foutus de notre gueule
mais en même temps ça a aidé à votre
succès le film va devenir un grand
classique et vous allez devenir une star
vous avez eu cette fois en dix ans le x
arrco awards ouais bon et vous avez eu
20 av no1
de lavit
absolument absolument laurent c'est
arrivé très vite c'était vraiment
vraiment grâce à rocco est installé à
nos manèges associé à votre sexe aussi
mais la moyenne est de 14 cm vous ces 22
quand même je sais même pas là bas non
non c'est vrai j'ai jamais vues réelles
et mozyr leur bright vous avez même un
sextoy à votre nom alors on le reconnaît
son sextoys parce que il n'est pas
circoncis et aux états unis beaucoup de
gens sont circoncis la plupart d'aller
vers des gens mais la plupart des faits
vous vous n'êtes pas circoncis et on va
regarder donc comme ça on pourra se
faire une idée je savais que j'avais
[Musique]
fait
une très bonne pub ah oui oui parce que
c'est marrant quoi sais pas mais en fait
je suis arrivé ce jour là et il avait
une liste de choses qu'ils voulaient que
je disais je leur ai dit [__] je vais
pas faire un truc sérieux pourparlers
m'habite en fait alors à près d'annaba
et spolient way magnifique actrice merci
avec qui il a eu trois enfants oui vous
êtes en couple avec kate and cross avec
qui il avait eu une petite fille oui
elle a arrêté de tourner ouais alors la
théorie bout mon nom mais elle est
jalouse elle est jalouse 6 et en dehors
des tournages tant que ça reste dans les
tournages tout va bien comprend elle m'a
connu dans dans le business donc elle
comprend que c'est un cercle très fermé
en fait français qui peut s'élargir
alors mais ils attendaient que je la
fasse que des vainqueurs à la rapide
alors avec kayden kross vous mettez en
scène votre vie de couple sur les
réseaux sociaux on vous appelle les
brangelina du porno
au fait des sketches humoristiques tout
public sur youtube oui en fait c'est sur
notre vie donc c'est bien sûr beaucoup
autour du porno mais on va regarder le
regard d un petit bout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça passe il fonde en semaine un épisode
d'à peu près cinq minutes et ouais ça
c'est assez drôle pour nous de faire ça
c'est vraiment vous êtes sur twitter la
plus grande plateforme de gaming du
monde trente mille followers qui vous
regardent jouer à fifa quoi oui ça
marche très bien c'est une plateforme de
jeu ou sur laquelle on peut on peut
jouer les gens vous regardent et il ya
un chat donc ils peuvent vous parler
directement et dernière question votre
fils de 9 ans ouais vous dites quoi
quand ils vous demandent que vous faites
dans la vie alors mon fils de 9 ans
c'est rien c'est très important pour moi
qu'il apprenne le métier dans deux mois
n'aura le métier qu'ils apprennent
devenant mois et donc j'ai commencé déjà
à lui en parler un petit peu je suis pas
sûr qu'il ait vraiment la notion de
sexualité tout ça
du coup je vais expliquer que j'étais
dans la production et que c'était des
films que pour adultes je vais expliquer
qu' il fallait pas qu'ils en parlent à
l'école je dis qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui aiment ce que je
fais mais que certaines personnes
n'aiment pas au kaki de tous les
québécois
merci à tous les partis non c'est le cas
merci à marc cherry dit merci d'avoir
été avec nous et toujours très heureux
désormais voilà j'étais là pis droit des
celtes et on se retrouve sur même après
la pub avec guy en 2017 et notre
bataille des idées consacré la
télévision avec gérard le vent de bruno
patino
[Musique]
re re re bonsoir luthérienne re re
bonsoir le talent des jeunes leur
touchante est toujours en compagnie le
christ imac ordinaire
[Applaudissements]
dans le match au ballon ma vie et on
regarde maintenant le best-of guillon
2017 temps
d'après une étude publiée par un site
britannique les gens d'extrême droite
serait sexuellement plus épanouie ah
ouais il paraît qu'au fn ça va ils sont
totalement libéré chaud bouillant très
imaginatif mais moi du wagner oui oui
c'est bon c'est bon appel - rudolf maury
d'olmes on a rien à mon dieu grec nîmois
le gagner et moore l'émoi du zemmour
appel - jeanne libère mois dès arabes ce
renvoi en amazone non pas en bretagne
lambèse je ne supporte pas les jaunes
les niakoués les fans de citron renvoie
la française à la tricolore plop moi ton
drapeau
ils sont très très fidèles pour
nationale qui vous à vos cils et sado
maso ceux qui ont besoin d'avoir mal
pour jouir mais moi du rail belge est là
bas j'ai envie de souffrir j'ai été
méchante avec moi fatima récite le coran
arrachement burqini unis mois sortent à
merveille ce soit la lapident mois
grand-place moi
j'étais encore
[Musique]
en même temps en même temps rester quand
même prudent je rappelle que le
conseiller municipal fn de manque la
ville a été retrouvé mort la semaine
dernière entouraient de sextoys un aigle
de la wehrmacht en bronze extrêmement
mal placé internationale le dit pardon
oui c'est vrai il ya un petit coup de
rabot serait oublier c'était très bien
on recommence
internationale
le djihadiste berrois mais ahmed arrêté
en suisse alors qu'il demandait l'asile
politique bah oui oui non ça se comprend
ancien nazi mafieux évadé fiscal la
suisse est prête à vous accueillir
mais djihadistes nous les suisses ont
une éthique quand même un minimum
justice
accusé de blanchiment de fraude fiscale
a sursauté encore jérémy peppers à lui
refaire pour voir faut que j'arrive à
les hisser
la
justice accusé de blanchiment de fraude
fiscale les balkanique conteste la
saisie de leur moulin de giverny par la
justice en évoquant un acharnement
judiciaire
c'est vrai que ça commence à faire
beaucoup après marrakech et saint-martin
leur pic le moulin de giverny non non
giverny c'est l'endroit où ils se sont
aimés il ya une valeur sentimentale très
forte est-ce qu'on pourrait pas imaginer
une soirée caritative
une sorte de téléthon où les gens
appellerait pour faire des promesses de
dons que les balkany retrouve une maison
bonsoir bonsoir soyez les bienvenus à ce
tout premier balkany ton pour
m'accompagner ce soir jérôme cahuzac
thomas thévenoud claude guéant bernard
tapie tous ont répondu présent pour
essayer de sauver le les époux balkany
deux bâtiments principaux de 600 et 2
sans intérêt c'est là où patrick a fait
cette première fausse déclaration
d'impôts c'est aussi là dans le pool
house qu'il s'est fait peur mais de vie
comme nation ou fille avec un 357 magnum
beaucoup beaucoup de souvenirs quelques
millions d'euros c'est la somme qu'il
faut réunir ce soir pour permettre aux
balkany de conserver leur manoir leur
refuge depuis 30 ans mobilité bout mots
je suis sûr que des gens qui ont envoyé
du pognon d'après nicolas sarkozy dès
que l'on devient français nos ancêtres
sont gaulois une phrase qui a soulevé un
véritable tollé mais non non il a raison
sarkozy nos ancêtres sont tous gaulois
tous vous avez sarkozix un petit gaulois
hystérique qui rêve de redevenir le chef
du village enfants il est tombé dans la
marmite de potion magique depuis ils
arrivent plus à maintenir ses épaules
toujours accompagné de la délicieuse
carla bruni qs la barthez du village dès
qu'elles chantent ils sont obligés de la
tâche et les animaux s'enfuit la pluie
tombe vous avez soporifique le chef nous
est faible incapable de choisir il se
rêvait en période électorale à ses côtés
son ministre des finances priapique ce
qui tripotent toutes les journalistes
qui croise avoir la gaule l'expression
vient de là
pour finir n'oublions pas balkanique ce
le voleur l'escroc qui a planqué tout
son argent en helvétie et xénophobie qu
ce personnage raciste intolérants bête
comme chou elle veut bouter tous les
étrangers hors de france hispanique
gothique arabique aucun doute possible
nous descendons tous des gaulois partout
tête
[Applaudissements]
on termine avec une belle image un beau
geste
alors que la primaire de droite est de
plus en plus violentes nicolas sarkozy a
dressé un tweet de soutien à son ami
alain juppé je veux un gigantesque blanc
pour que chaque personne âgée puisse
finir sa vie en étant respecté
il n'y a aucune raison
qu au soir du 27 novembre quand j'aurai
gagné les primaires que je laisse alain
juppé finir sa vie dans un hospice de
bande
je ne le ferai pas je veux qu'il soit
placé dans une maison de retraite
accueillante et qu'ils fassent des
activités à 72 ans on n'est pas fichu
thierry ardisson
[Musique]
et même s'ils allaient diminuer et peut
tout à fait devenir délégué chef de
table ou responsable des ateliers de
sudoku et je me battrai jusqu'au bout
pour qu'il obtienne ce poste je vais
vous dire une chose derrière dix jours
en maison de retraite on a la photo
alain alain est un animateur et un
danseur hors pair à la semaine prochaine
voilà c'est investir dans le trou ici la
semaine prochaine et d'ici là au théâtre
dejazet voilà on passe maintenant à la
battle des idées
[Musique]
et c'est le producteur gérard louvin et
l'ancien directeur des programmes et des
antennes de france télévisions bruno
patino que nous retrouverons sur ce
plateau après le magnéto battle ce soir
la télé écoles ou opium du peuple
[Musique]
la télévision c'était le média dont
xxème siècle elle nous a informés sur ce
qui se passait dans le monde ce matin à
l'aube sur le mur de berlin une nouvelle
brèche sur place de capital elle nous a
appris plein de choses intéressantes
dans ce domaine précisé le commandant
cousteau le succès a été difficile les
couples elle vous a aussitôt passé de
bons moments et tout ça sans bouger de
son canapé sauf qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes au 21ème siècle et que les
nouvelles générations délaisse la télé
pour d'autres écrans bref si la télé ne
saurait à vendre at elle encore un
avenir depuis quelques années la télé
nous propose plein de nouvelles chaînes
mais les programmes eux restent les
mêmes la dernière grande nouveauté
remonte à 2001 avec la diffusion du loft
sur m6 au début la télé réalité presque
en dalle
mais depuis m6 a créé un fil des
missions où les anonymes deviennent les
vedettes comme dans top chef ou la
nouvelle star au lieu de rester enfermé
en studio les animateurs de m6 vont à la
rencontre du public pour les aider à
trouver un appartement comme stéphane
plaza 90 mètres carrés tout en barque ou
pour les aider à changer de look comme
cristina cordula
de son côté france 2 fait tout le
contraire dans ses nouvelles émissions
de l'après midi les animateurs restent
enfermés en studio et ils papotent il
papote avec leurs qualités et leurs
chroniqueurs résultat les audiences ont
tellement mauvaise que vincent meslet le
patron de france 2 c'était dirait le
limogeage de vincent meslet le patron
des programmes de france 2 qui n'a rien
vu venir et a appris son limogeage
quelques heures avant cette annonce
désormais pour faire de l'audience il
faut s'adapter aux téléspectateurs c'est
le seul est cyril hanouna sur s'est vite
grâce de sept millions fans que son
émission culte où les différents réseaux
sociaux oui c'est exactement ce qui
plaît ou ne plaît pas à son public c'est
loupé
chaque jour adapter son programme en
fonction des commentaires de la veille
c'est exactement ce que fait netflix a
une très très grande échelle avant de se
lancer dans la série house of cards
m'expliquer ça proposait 10 bandes
annonces différentes à 700 millions
d'abonnés dans le monde ça a permis
d'analyser précisément ce qui plaisait
ou plaisait pas au public résultat la
série est devenue un énorme succès alors
sachant que netflix investi 6 milliards
par an dans ce nouveau programme soit
deux fois le budget de france
télévisions autant dire que la bonne
vieille télé à papa a du souci à se
faire voilà c'était l'élite monaco nous
dans l'image de julien grave j'ai en moi
mon soir
des producteurs de musique de cinéma que
ce quelqu'un que bien sûr de télévision
on vous voit sacré soirée ciel mon mardi
sans aucun doute j'en oublie nrj awards
miss france enfin
bienvenu dans l'immédiat
bruno battu au mans ce soir
vous êtes ancien directeur des
programmes et les antennes de france
télévisions vous êtes aujourd'hui
directeur éditorial d'arreter et vous
publié chez grasset un livre intitulé
télévision bienvenue parmi nous alors
d'en voter la télé de papa est mort de
bruno vous écrivez la télévision souffre
d'un paradoxe elle est faite par ce
qu'ils ont vécu son apogée quand elle
était le média sûr de lui et dominateur
hypnotisant ses téléspectateurs
mobilisant les masses donc elle est
morte la télé papa t'es de papa oui mais
elle se réinvente donc c'est assez
vraiment sur d'autres écrans en fait le
téléviseur
est regardé par une population de plus
en plus vieillissante mais les images
sont partout donc la télé on a du mal à
définir maintenant alors pourquoi elle
est morte la télé de papa non mais
d'abord un truc les images c'était rare
avant donc un effet magique d'être
devant un poste avec des images dans les
achats sont partout et donc la télé elle
est noyée dans ce torrent d'image donc
elle n'est pas morte mais vraiment elle
comme elle est partout elle est un peu
nulle part elle se réinvente totalement
et donc on est dans un moment assez
particulier où il ya à la fois encore la
télé de papa fait par des êtres humains
la télé par exemple drucker c'était papa
on peut le dire oui mais c'est pas
péjoratif non non c'est à dire qu'il ya
des gens effectivement dont vous êtes
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je porterai
un moment donné
un nom des gens qui ont duré des gens
qui dure qui sont là qui va permettre
aux du répit aux fesses médias et puis
notre côté il ya un espèce de système
qui arrivent des systèmes chargés
d'image fait par de grandes
collectivités et c'est ce moment là qui
est intéressant c'est entre les deux
tout est dit dans le sujet ouais non
mais c'est exactement ça parce que il ya
moi je dis toujours j'ai fait énormément
de choses il ya avant 2000 et après 2 me
mais celui et celui qui n'a pas compris
qu'on qu'après 2000 tout avait changé il
est mort il est mort moi j'ai travaillé
quand même pour la télé canapé ce qu'on
appelle la télé canapé c'est où il ya le
petit enfants de cinq six ans et a le
grand frère de 16 ans il ya là-bas mans
il ya la grand-mère 18 vite on retient
sacrée soirée vite vite ya drucker vie
dit maintenant qu'est-ce qui fait le
ghost ou quatre ans il est sur sa petite
tablette
il s'amuse le gosse de 16 ans à la télé
c'est même plus que c'est les parents
ils ont la maman est là le papa est là
et c'est la télévision c'est fini c'est
c'est je pense que ça va être très très
dur à renouveler mois la télévision
maintenant c'est les ordi c'est les
tablettes mais j'ai peur qui est que que
ce soit difficile j'ai vraiment peur que
que cette télé ne se développe pas soit
parce que bah ouais parce qu'il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas les moyens on n'a pas les
moyens de la télévision quand on fait un
prime sur tf1 ces huit cent mille euros
c'est 1 million d'euros
moi je vois pas quand j'ai vu arriver
toutes les petites chaînes je me suis ça
y est c'est formidable il va y avoir des
nouveaux animateurs il va y aura des
nouveaux concepts citez-moi des nouveaux
concepts citez-moi des nouveaux
animateurs parce que et je finis là
dessus vous avez connu ça par coeur
avant une production il y avait le
producteur et son animateur il bossait
comme des malades et tout ça maintenant
on achète des concepts à l'étranger on
prend un animateur là ou là et on fait
le truc et c'est comme ça que ça marche
pas il ya un problème supplémentaire
c'est que des concepts à l'étranger n'a
plus tellement c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
tellement de grands formats aujourd'hui
à acheter je mets à jour nonce paolini
quand j'étais conseil à tf1 longtemps me
dit explique moi pourquoi n'y a plus
beaucoup de créations je dis je vais
t'expliquer un producteur dont vous êtes
il a un concept qui vient de créer il
arrive pour voir les directions et là on
lui dit ça marche ou ça marche hollande
ça marche en angleterre ça ben non c'est
le crès and on prend pas le risque qu
est ce qui fait d'un mec cada boîte à
faire vivre et il va au mip ils achètent
des concepts et julie fait le concept et
pendant ce temps là il ne crée pas parce
que bon standing travail il fait
travailler sa société mais il a pas le
temps de réfléchir
c'est exactement ça
vraiment pas les vieux pont aux côtés de
vieux cons ensemble
trois vieux pour les 2-3
non
alors tiens voilà un sujet qui vous qui
nous concerne la télé doit elle coache
les gens parce que aujourd'hui la télé
n'est dupe lui comme du temps de le rtf
aujourd'hui la télé dit aux gens comment
comment il faut vite vous vous êtes à
fond là dessus oui moi je sais pas
contre moi je trouve que c c c c c bien
de d'expliquer aux gens et dépasser en
savoir à quelqu'un de quelque chose
qu'on connaît pas qui c'est difficile
d'accès et je trouve que c'est plus
simple si on peut se documenter par des
émissions télé comment comment est ce
qu'on peut faire à part acheté un
appartement quels sont les pièges à
éviter
moi pour la mode
il faut savoir qui est la mode dans les
années 80 elle n'était pas du tout
accessible et que aujourd'hui c'est on à
arriver à avoir des prix sympas partout
et donc du coup il faut justement dire
aux gens comment est-ce qu'il faut hâter
ce talent parce que on ne savait pas
trop même si c'est pour ça c'est la télé
coaching quoi ouais c'est la télé
coaching mais moi je suis pas aussi
pessimiste je veux dire parce que il ya
un paradoxe de dire la télé ni du cul
cul la télé fait plus ça il ya des
images partout et où en même temps les
gens passent par les images pour le
savoir pour ceux pour se rencontrer on
voit partout dans tes réseaux sociaux et
donc moi je crois pas du tout que que la
télé école du peuple soit en train de
disparaître ce qui est assez que c'est
le canal unique école du peuple unique
qui tendait à disparaître c'est la
classe et d'école aussi dans l'école
aussi il ya plus de classe unique pour
tout le monde moi ce que je crois quand
même c'est que c'est que la télé a un
rôle justement paradoxal aujourd'hui de
cultiver une certaine rareté des images
et enfin moi je suis assez optimiste sur
le fait de pouvoir diffuser des images
qui font sens pas forcément sur l'écran
de télévision mais ça n'a pas
d'importance quel jugement porter sur la
télé d'aujourd'hui nous comme on est on
est beaucoup à l'observer pour essayer
de faire des sketches et des parodies
c'est plus en plus difficile enfin de
fourche showa l'arrêter c'est à dire que
c'est devenu les programmes sont devenus
tellement trop ça semble vulgaire du
coup mais ressemble trop et ça semble à
côté donc c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dit
bon voilà on est dépassé et là par les
frichtis des machins comme ça c'est pour
ça qu'on a lâché la télé n'est pas morte
excusez moi la télé n'est pas bon
c'était non non mais moi non plus mais
la télé de 11 millions de
téléspectateurs comme on faisait ça là
les morts et quant au coaching c'est
vrai que c'est formidable et c'est pas
très original non plus c'est la mode
c'est la bouffe c'est l'appartement moi
je peux vous trouvez un concept demain
matin comme ça il tient hop je vais
faire ça avec comment élever son chien
et hop et on voit s'étaler moins
compliqué qu'on a inventé les grandes
émissions s'est noyé ses parents à
mourir et il ya plein de concerts
alors oui ça peut être sympa est pas moi
et débat qui est
très longue série alors à part quotidien
de yann barthès sur tf1 et ambition
intime de notre amie karine le marchand
sur m6 il ya beaucoup de flops sur
france2 surtout est-ce qu'il faut des
programmes et ou persévérer ah c'est pas
à moi de là vous avez eu ce charme ah
ouais ça je peux en parler ouais vous
l'avez débranché au bout de trois mois
au bout de 4 way et aujourd'hui elle
pense que c'était très long trop long ça
l'était peut-être trop ce que ce que ce
que j'ai appris sur sophia aram c'est
plusieurs choses c'est d'abord c'est
très difficile de faire rentrer des
nouveaux visages dans l'est dans les
foyers et donc on peut se plaindre que
c'est toujours les mêmes animateurs les
mêmes animatrice mais en même temps
faire rentrer de nouvelles personnes et
très compliqué succès sa fille vous
l'avait poussé pour qu'elles apprennent
à nager dans le grand bain il n'y avait
pas eu de sas de décompression comme
pierrick comme les gens en troisième
partie de soirée ensuite en deuxième et
puis maintenant on accepte mais sophia
aram c'est violent quand même
clive de de lynchage quand même ouais
c'était violent pour elle que ce soit
violent pour les patrons de chaîne c'est
normal c'est le jeu que ce soit violent
pour l'animatrice j'ai trouvé ça anormal
surtout qui avait une coloration quand
même qu'ils étaient assez particulière
moi j'habitais à l'époque chez cyril
hanouna le concept de huit mois le
concept d'un drame il y avait un conseil
à donner c'est toujours pareil quand les
gens disent par exemple pourquoi
l'émission de thomas thouroude ne marche
pas je dis ce qui serait étonnant c'est
que ça marche mais pas finir comme
inquiète pas connu et bien sûr dans une
émission y'a pas de conciliation ça
c'est eux qui les achètent les émissions
ils sont en bas oui parce qu'ils sont
pas bons
mais c'est tout j'irai tout ça
les émissions culturelles c'est
compliqué regarder même
la société de l'eau en bon yann barthès
qui est une bonne boîte de prod
s'appelle bangoumi ils n'arrivent pas à
l'émission qu'ils ont fait avec léa
salamé l'émission culturelle marche pas
du tout stupéfiants elle démarre en fait
en fait ça c'est un cce bon c'est une
vraie question et c'est intéressant
parce qu'en fait quand on voit il ya
tellement de chaînes aujourd'hui que si
vous faites une émission en disant
attention c'est une émission culturelle
même si vous la réussissez vous aurez
des gens qui veulent voir une émission
culturelle donc sur une grande chaîne
vous ferez six points d'audience en
deuxième partie de soirée sur arte vous
ferez 4 ou 4 et demi mais si on veut
aller un peu au delà il faut enfin moi
je le crois mais de la culture en
contrebande mais c'est vrai que le
service public devrait mettre de la
culture par tout d'abord aussi bien dans
les jeux dans les variétés dans les
magasins ce que c'est l'enjeu en fait
d'en mettre partout moi j'ai la chance
je travaille sur une chaîne aujourd'hui
qui en met partout donc je suis plutôt
heureux de ça ouais mais je pense que
c'est le vrai enjeu ouais c'est à dire
que dans les émissions de divertissement
dans les jeux comme vous le dites et
c'est en mètres est ce que le juge lui
devrait pas
spectacular is et la culture parce que
c'est ça le problème aussi c'est que la
culture pour les gens c'est on notera
pas les mouches avec du vinaigre mais
c'est l'enjeu c'est à dire qu'il faut
télévision et la culture où l'internet
is et quand on fait de l'internet c'est
ça si on la met si on l'a parc c'est
très bien parce qu'on attire les gens
qui ont l'habitude mais mais des gens
qui rentrent en librairie c'est
l'électeur si vous gagnez des lecteurs
c'est pas en librairie que ça se joue
c'est à dire de librairie c'est la même
chose pour les émissions culturelles
alors le csa donc le csa belle bande
dans le cul lettres langues sciences
[Rires]
c'est pas du tout ce que je me suis hd
l'avenir me donnera raison
ah ouais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une course au buzz
à cause d'internet tout le monde peut
faire du buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
etc donc c'est la porte ouverte aux
dérapages et csa sait plus où donner de
la tête l'histoire de jean michel bergue
je dirai pas si la raison s'il a tort
enfin c'est ya de cinq ans se serait
passé complètement inaperçu j pas que
c'est bien ou pas bien mais dans ce coup
ça prend une ampleur et le csa qui se
mêle de ça moi je trouve que bruno
réseaux sociaux maintenant c'est une
caisse de résonance permanent donc de
toutes façons ça prouve d'ailleurs que
la télé n'est plus aussi puissante
puisqu'elle a besoin de cette caisse de
résonance pour atteindre son plein effet
oui c'est ça et puis en même temps il ya
une course à l'hyper divertissement
alors on peut décider de pas y
participer et ça c'est le bon plan là ça
tu plantes l'info quand on voit les
clashs clients on se tape ça sur tous
les réseaux sociaux toutes les impôts
pendant trois jours et sa suppléante la
guerre en syrie l'histoire de jean
michel maire est plus important que
c'est passé dans le monde hippique c'est
ça qui dit qu'est ce qu'ils font il
donne un avertissement deux heures
la jeune fille d'aller sur le site du
csa pour déposer une plainte à formuler
à remplir c'est très très facile je vous
le dis je voulais vous plaindre de
laurent baffie
comme en 40
et alors gérard votre nouvelle
production musicale c'est aux dinos y
aura deux avant première le 21 et 22
novembre à bobigny où c'est quoi
justement c'est là où on peut amener de
la culture c'est un pop symphonique ce
ne sont que des jeunes musiciens c'est
un jeune chef d'orchestre on ne joue que
ddv x est à dire ça va 2 pierre fa
stravinsky mais à adel jackson et on
amène au milieu de tout ça on peut
glisser un morceau à l'arpp qui est un
peu plus difficile on va y aller alors
oui mais tu es invité carton dans ma
poche pas lui
c'est quoi j'aime bien la rep' le mot de
la fin gerra je vous aime au
voilà c'est jusqu'à luthériens d'autres
coupes du samedi avec christina
[Musique]
cabinet grégoire du
mât
[Applaudissements]
alex ans
je
[Applaudissements]
et
bono
non
bien cette mission
à 19 heures et d'ici là que mâchoire
soit c'est salutaire
[Musique]
à
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu